i see confusion online about unity
2020's goal of dealing with opportunity
hoarding and rent seeking
as some view these as abstract
assertions can you provide specific
examples of these behaviors in practice
and how the current duopoly enables them
so let me before you answer that it's a
big question um and we're not going to
spend
you know that could be a whole hour but
i also i don't remember if it was in the
q a last time
i also actually stopped you at one point
and said let's just let's talk about
what rent seeking
is because some number of people are
going to just think rent and think
you know cancel rent which is one of the
you know like abolish the police defund
the police cancel rent
um so that we we have talked about that
recently
as well in an attempt to
to deal with the obvious problems of
always speaking in abstractions
yep um so let us talk a little bit about
rent seeking as it exists and why unity
2020 which does not have a platform nor
does it aim to have a platform would
address it
we have many instances in which we have
a solvable problem that persistently
remains unsolved so our incredibly
cruddy way
of paying for and allocating the right
to
health care is a primary example why can
we not figure out a system
in which your health conditions are
dealt with as a matter of distributing
the hazard over a risk pool
it's not complex what the problem is
that is to be solved nor is it complex
what the solution is
the problem is that we have
a an industry in charge of something
which markets cannot be allowed to do
because they will inevitably do it
poorly so
if you are in the insurance game and i
don't mean if you are
providing insurance which could be done
well but if you are in the insurance
game in the sense that you are an
insurance company
in competition with other insurance
companies you will inevitably discover
that the way to win the insurance game
is to ensure the people who are least
likely to need insurance and disinsure
the people who are most likely to need
the insurance
so the job of insurance which is to
neutralize
the risks that we face when somebody has
done nothing wrong and has gotten a
cancer
we can distribute the cost of
paying for the treatment of that cancer
across the entire population basically
you don't know whether you're going to
get one or you're not going to get one
but we can all agree
that i would like it not to be ruinous
if i get cancer
and so we can distribute the risk across
a large population
but if my insurance company is in the
profit making business
and it discovers well actually we'd like
to give the insurance
in case you get a cancer to people who
are least likely to get it and we would
like to disinsure the people who are
most likely to get it because that's the
way to enhance the profits
then what we end up doing is disinsuring
lots of people who are equally deserving
of being protected from this hazard so
in essence the solution involves
neutralizing the market forces
that surround insurance now who do you
think opposes that
people who are making a profit in
insurance why can't we solve that
problem
why do they have a vote well they have a
vote because of the way
that things like lobbying influence
policy so
persistently we are scratching our heads
and we have two parties
that pretend that there's some big
disagreement on how to make the system
work
right that's going to explain why they
fail to solve it
decade after decade when in fact they
fail to solve it decade after decade
because they're both in the pockets of
these insurers whose racket involves
making money by preventing people from
having insurance who should have it
that's the racket right so that's
rent-seeking behavior
the insurance companies are providing
some service right
but they are also getting a ton of
profit from something that is not only
not providing any useful service
but it is interrupting the service that
they're supposed to be providing so
why would a unity 2020 ticket address
that because if you got patriots in the
white house
then what you would have are people who
had no incentive to keep the system
going and were in a position to call it
out
right there's an awful lot of power in
that it never happens the parties
arrange for that not to happen so that
we never solve the problem so that
they're real constituents who
include the medical insurers never have
to
face the terrible system that they've
built so
i hope that explains it
you